I loved episode 10 and I specifically
loved
um when the end of the episode when with
the where your character says you know I
can't swim I love the delivery of that
line and I love uh just that scene it's
like it's heartbreaking
um and I'm just curious can you talk a
little bit about filming that and how
you wanted to deliver that line yeah I
mean that that was one of you know one
of the great things about having that
Arc and obviously as an actor I knew
that that was I was going to arrive at
that point
um and when
so so that's why I I wanted to make him
a sort of bullish and
um really kind of unsympathetic early on
and then and then actually with the
effect of you know Cassian and he going
head to head and then the moment of
realization that they're never gonna
ever gonna be released and and that sort
of reigniting his Humanity in a way and
then really in episode 10 it he he goes
on this journey of
which which is an absolutely part of his
his core belief system is is that the
power of the individual can help others
and you can if you reunite you can
change you know you can change the shape
of the future you know that that comes
flooding back to him and you actually
see the process of that happening which
ends up with you know the the kind of
the sacrifice if you like uh and that
and that scene at the end where we tried
it in different ways we tried that line
in in lots of different ways of him
almost being angry
um of of uh you know without being
without being too sentimental kind of
like seeing his own Doom we try to you
know and and then eventually we we sort
of settled into this this area of of is
almost coming to terms with it and and I
think that sort of pathos really
that moment of pathos probably was was
the way to go so so but it was a it was
a really explorative
um scene to do and especially yeah for
me for my character but it was an
amazing scene to shoot with with
everybody diving you know diving off and
jumping to freedom and and just this
sort of sense of
you know vertigo and fear and and and
and and phobia of of of water you know
it just was yeah it was an interesting
layer very interesting layer to play
yeah one of the things that I love about
Andor is how it just feels believable
what's happening to the characters and
the thing I especially love is how every
few episodes Cassian is running into
different people the way you would in
real life you know like he I I don't
want to get specific but it's just you
know he's bouncing from situation to
situation and often with TV shows you're
not stuck with but you're with the same
actors All Season there's no
believability that anyone is really
gonna die or get hurt and that's just
not the case on Andor oh no no
absolutely I mean that's that's the
genius of Tony's Vision really he he and
and and and which again makes it makes
it such a great Every Man story because
because they're all so incredibly
um
you know they all feel real they just
all feel everyone as you say all the
characters and their and their
idiosyncrasies and their and their
functions and and their you know complex
personal
lives kind of all intermingled sort of
really make it feel like a world that
you that that you that you could go
through that he quite you could easily
relate to and the politics the the the
the the the the Thriller aspect of it
you know it's it's it feels just uh you
know it's very satisfying very
satisfying to watch and I mean I've
watched the other episodes you know like
a fan so
it's been incredible uh my last thing
for you because I'm just about out of
time when you signed on did Tony say to
you it's going to be for three episodes
or did he say like you might there's a
possibility of more and my part two uh
now that you've seen how incredible it
is have you called him and been like hey
man I really would like to direct an
episode in season two oh wow I I hadn't
thought of that I mean you know the the
thing is it's I
yeah that's that would be an amazing
thing
I don't know what the future holds for
for Kino Lloyd uh who knows he might be
stuck on that ship and or whatever I
don't know
um but let's see I I I can't I haven't
had any discussions yet but but
um I don't know we'll have to see what
everybody thinks of it and and the out
and the outcome I mean I
I think it's
look if even if if Kino Lloyd goes no
further the answer is there's short
answer to your question is yeah that
would be that would be a thrilling thing
to do to be to be part of uh to be part
on the other side of the on the other
side of the camera for for this world
would be amazing yeah listen um I I have
to uh uh rap but I really just want to
say to you sincerely loved your work on
Andor
um I and I I can't say enough amazing
things about the show there's not enough
vocab out of my I don't have enough
language to express how much I love the
show
well thank you I appreciate that and I
agree with you I mean in terms of the
show I do I I really think it's it is a
beautiful piece of Storytelling
um just real fast how long did you
actually shoot for well you said a few
weeks but how long was was it to shoot
the three episodes
I mean it was over the course of about I
think it must have been about five or
six weeks I think okay I'm just curious
how what it what it actually took but
listen man again I just want to say
congrats and uh good luck with the rest
of your speed dating and uh I can't you
know uh thank you so much for your time
uh thanks Steve great to see you as ever